Prashad are making vegetable kofta
steamed and spiced chopped vegetables
encasing the potato patty deep-fried
then served in a fresh tomato sauce the
sauce is quite hot medium spicy midges
lots of flavor you need don't put those
copters in there too early because stand
to break up a vegetable cough so it's
very hard to get rice for some of the
elements they can explode and sort of
disintegrates getting the timing right
on this dish it's critical somin Al and
Cal she need to work together perfectly
I mean look at here what are you doing
come on silly it's on hello just a
minute in her own kitchen may now
struggle with the pressure and he just
came out on top and tonight there's no
supportive husband Bobby in the kitchen
to help her by now I'm pretty sure if I
know mineral and my mom they'll be right
in the middle of the cooking and just
totally focused on giving you the best
food
I'm in it but this is my kitchen I'm
announced by out of a comfort zone
anybody seen my onion it was here
there you go look at me after every
table we have to play down but you can't
continue working in a mess yeah thank
you
look after you comedians yeah can I have
that please let me go do you have some
oh wait look appoint me now please i
cute service go let's go please no it's
for I sit for and worry about that it's
cool listen to me listen to me I'm here
I'm here to help you
you're confusing yourself not me far
away please thank you it's a very very
very lot of pressure
me and mum were going through a lot of
race a lot to duel it's very complicate
this so it's made time so this I am I'm
just panicking
so vegetable kofta temple 3 please how
is everybody this was very very buggy
it's lovely shake the presentation is
immaculate and beautiful looking that's
really nice isn't it last time please
min out Kelsey
volkoff's always nice very nice
okay down both of you well done so hot
service is over so it's time to discover
my distinguished guests thought of both
restaurants dishes starting with a
brilliant really good see let's talk the
jalfrezi how was that for you adult
first second combination is very good
also the paneer also I found it's tasty
it's not only the cheese it has got a
spice yes presentation also remarkably
dirty that's very very traditional this
is very hard to make because of the
Kafka's were nice nice and delicious and
you could taste the fresh ginger that
was great
it look good as well dishes awesome the
only thing I'd say rice is supposed to
be nice and fluffy and separately
they've got some other got this big
profits right but overall I think this
is excellent
phenomenally proud the dish that I've
made today you know I definitely think
that we've done our very best my diners
clearly loved the food though neither
restaurant quite achieved perfection now
it's up to me to choose a winner
whatever I decide will affect the future
of both these restaurants